[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchos años después frente al pelotón de
fusilamiento de un banco hipotecario
antonio ojos tristes había de recordar
aquella tarde remota en que su padre lo
llevó a conocer la playa cádiz era
entonces una isla de viento con
palacetes y arrabales construidos a la
orilla de un mar de aguas diáfanas que
se precipitaban por un lecho de piedras
antiguas con formas y nombres como si
existieran
basta decir estas pequeñas
palabras y algo se enciende por dentro y
ya todos sabemos de qué obra estamos
hablando
100 años de soledad
se terminó de imprimir que no de editar
y publicar se terminó de imprimir el 30
de mayo de 1967 y tres meses antes nací
yo
habrá quien pueda pensar que esto es una
manera muy frívola
y aprovecho y aquí pido perdón un poco
por la adaptación que he hecho de los
primeros párrafos del libro de una
manera muy muy frívola de intentar
buscar una especie una especie de
conexión entre este libro y yo pero
para poder nacer en febrero hay que
gestar en mayo
y ahí está la conexión
ahí está mi conexión
es la la manera de buscar mi conexión
con este libro que es el libro de
cabecera porque es como si fuera el
libro de mi familia prácticamente 100
años de soledad es el lugar mágico
macondo
juego de naipes macondo tribu errante
que también lo es
macondo un árbol
macondo para gabriel garcía márquez
cádiz para mí un árbol como mejor dicho
dos árboles porque aquí habría que
barajar esas dos alternativas por un
lado está el árbol genealógico de mi
familia y por otro lado está
el árbol de la ciudad que me permite
poder ver el bosque porque bueno estamos
hecho al fin al cabo de personas en este
caso mi familia donde abundan los
hombres de ojos tristes y la ciudad que
lo atrapó
les cuento mi bisabuelo se llamaba
antonio tenía los ojos grises y sombríos
y murió tres veces
la primera vez no quedó satisfecho
la segunda la familia no fue al sepelio
en clara respuesta a su negativa por no
querer morirse cuando le tocaba con lo
cual la familia no quedó satisfecha y él
no quedó satisfecho
y la tercera vez
le tocó le cogió en un colmado ahí cerca
del muelle mientras cantaba una
seguiriya
al 7 por desesperado eso sí el tercio
flamenco lo acabó
pero lo acabó cayéndose al suelo lo que
se conoce tal mente como un cante rodado
fue entonces cuando mi abuelo dejó dos
frases a la familia en herencia para que
la pudiéramos usar cuando quisiéramos
en la boca que sabe a canción de sangre
mi abuelo se llamaba antonio y tenía los
ojos
negros y perdidos
dos días antes de morir
reunió todo el dinero que tenía compró
un billete de tren hasta donde le daban
y se fue
junto a un río por no llorar
fue cocinero en un barco
y náufrago cinco veces oficialmente más
de 80 para la clientela
se lo tragó vivo una pescadilla
la misma a la misma pescadilla qué año
más tarde pescara pericón de cádiz que
nadie sabe si era una pescadilla un
vaquero una dorada pero lo que sí
sabemos es que cada ojo de la pescadilla
era así
eso sí lo sabemos pero pues mi abuelo se
lo tragó vino una pescadilla pero fue
entregado salir salvo a la costa
mauritana por 12345 caballitos de mar
el día que yo nací como la copla se
podía leer
en mis ojos
marrones
y melancólico
los ojos tristes el mismo nombre que mi
bisabuelo y que mi abuelo pero lo de
descubrir la luz eso ocurrió en la
azotea de la casa de mi abuela
mientras ella atendía la ropa yo estaba
en un capacho ahí en telar la ropa
recién lavada
y me enamoré
ay me enamoré
y desde entonces sigo perdidamente
enamorado de esta ciudad
y no he hecho otra cosa que escribirle
porque es mi manera de entregarle
también mi parte de amor
mi gran amor porque fue mi primer amor
hay personas que
que quieren y hay personas que se
acostumbran a que otras las quieran
yo la amo
no lo puedo evitar y cada día intento
recuperar ese cariño intento buscar de
alguna manera la memoria de mis pasos
que se inicia inevitablemente en la
puerta de mi infancia y me gustaría
hacerlo con ustedes así que si no les
importa
porque esto es un acto de fe esto es no
es más que un acto de amor esto es amor
puro y duro' me gustaría si lo tienen a
bien que este paseo que vamos a realizar
lo hagamos pero con los ojos cerrados ya
les indicará yo cuando abrirlos que lo
van a abrir
hay una escalerilla
desde arriba veo a mi madre vender el
pescado por las casas
dos niños comen la cal de la pared suelo
traída de las mismas indias
barrio pobre para ellos y primo que aquí
no es gitano
cientos de cármenes cigarreras
demasiadas cruces para los apostólicos
folclóricos romanos adiós o caldo
apartamento a pelar me pillan
no hace falta reloj hay sonidos que
marcan los momentos los olores de los
guisos anuncian las horas próximas
baches en las esquinas de los caminos se
perfila el ayuntamiento'
y su plaza con siluetas de olas perladas
en el suelo
hago un guiño al arco del barrio más
antiguo de occidente el hombre de las
barbas me avisa que acaban de llegar los
nuevos tebeos veo la sombra de mi
bisabuelo mandando fabricar un anillo un
joyero comunista se formó aún en la
arteria de la calle mastodóntica aparece
de pronto la catedral con sus dos
ambientes de los pioneros abajo y el
nuevo clásico arriba como la misma
sociedad gaditana dos mujeres gritan
entre ellas como si hablaran allí en la
puerta de mi casa a vivir un hombre y
medio que era pintor que sí le gustaría
posar para erc y me dijo que yo soy como
esta ciudad que nunca se peina por las
mañanas que sólo se abre los ojos ella
vive y tú que le contesta este amarillo
nada más pintado allá
los coches circulan por la plaza salen
por peteneras bajaron desplomado otros
machos caletas algunas señoras re venían
y flamencos de cuevas azules jugando a
la última carta la gente tropieza entre
sí se abre la veda de la locura
colectiva los hijos del levante han
tomado lo que es suyo el proveedor y su
abrigo clandestino las obras
interminables de las casas con sus
tripas abiertas el ancho del embudo
eclesiástico achicando a la multitud
andando hacia mí viene un ciego
disparando fotografías con sus flashes
toñito recuerda la realidad supera
siempre la fricción
con los políticos hay que tener siempre
a mano una posición de censura
la prosa la prosa el verso es otra cosa
hace años él me enseñó a leer las calles
de cádiz las calles que no tienen forma
del libro abierto no tienen apenas
historias que contar yo siempre tengo
los ojos muy abiertos por lo mismo medio
el ciego
la gente no mira hacia arriba la gente
tienen miedo a caerse cuando anda y hay
aquí que no caben en descubrir otras
maravillas
la gente va lenta pero con mucha prisa
rugen los estómagos porque saben que
está próximo al mercado me pierdo en
algunos patios donde se ha parado el
tiempo en el mejor café entra cuchillo
por mi olfato remojado con los aromas de
las flores un león se come las líneas de
mi mano cuidado por la vista este
marinero mío
los abastos la jerga las carreras el
puro espectáculo de la vida la vida del
barrio la mar del barrio la frontera
entre los locos de los gatos voy de la
mano con mis primos por la orilla
llamando a las piedras incluso por sus
apellidos me mira el gigante milenario
cueva y cascada cada domingo aquí
estamos a salvo de los franceses brazos
de titanes son de piedra y se notan cada
atalaya con su barco cazas casas nobles
balcones nobles los 2 cádiz de nuevo
falla se lava las manos otra vez hay
quien sabe leer el agua dulce en los
pozos como hay quien sabe leer la vida
en los pozos de café
saludo al dragón del arte de ello cañón
y lotería en la esquina cada uno a su
suerte materia está rodeando al qadi en
una esquina impecable se deben ir al
guapo de cádiz guapo de palabra guapo
guapo te queremos que te huevo ya está
feo
que lo primero que hace el guapo arma
despertarse de la esquela del diario por
su aparece su nombre por si se
arreglaron
huele a petróleo fenicio en su ida y
vuelta en el vapor chalupa la activa del
bastinazo los caciques emplean a su
antojo
fernando quiñones se duermen sobre una
montaña de boquerones moré en la aduana
atento al contrabando el ombligo del
mundo
la mentalidad amurallada por más que te
amputen todo lo sigo sintiendo mañana
seguiré otra senda eso es lo mágico de
este realismo que todos los caminos que
llevan a ti subo con las ruinas del
castillo de un conde de un duque no era
ni conde ni duque pero ahí tienes un
castillo veo el féretro de agustina de
aragón y la lluvia de lágrimas por
fermín salvochea hay que vivir aquí
dentro de ahí dentro de sí para contarlo
camino sobre un suelo sobre un suelo
sobre un suelo césar inaugura el teatro
a que aquí hay el mismo sueño el que iba
a ser emperador campo de vendavales en
el horizonte se cruzan los azules
esto no es una isla
otro que se casa en la carcel matarifes
de lo jondo la puerta de tierra
ya pueden abrir los ojos
ahora comprendo que todo se reduce
simplemente se reduce al sentarse junto
a un río por no llorar acreditara que
vive una pescadilla y te rescate en
12.300 caballitos de mar
a saber morir tres veces y quedar
satisfecho a mirar esta ciudad con ojos
de fotógrafo y dejar también flashes
como por ejemplo dios no es hipster
no haya manera de olvidarte
y a no tenerle miedo a la muerte cuando
la boca te sepa canción de sangre y de
mil en un colmado frente al muelle que
hoy es sede de cualquier banco
hipotecario que emir injustamente a los
ciudadanos por encima del hombro
haciendo que seamos nosotros su pelotón
de fusilamiento y poder dejar esa frase
la segunda en herencia a todos vosotros
que me dejó mi bisabuelo el corazón es
como el tazón
o tiene robo o no tirado bo
yo soy yo soy todo esto y mucho menos
y créanme nos vivimos en ciudades
distintas en la misma quizá algún
cromosoma compartamos miren yo voy a
hacer una cosa
voy a dejar este libro aquí por si en
cualquier momento
les llega la curiosidad les pica
hagan como yo un acto de fe un acto de
amor
disfrútenla me enamoré s
y ahora sin más yo me voy a ir por el
camino viejo
el camino viejo que conduce a la playa
la playa que me enseñó una tarde mi
padre no les ha hablado yo de la playa y
mi padre
eso es otra maravillosa historia de amor
bueno tal vez en otro momento muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]